foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar single
cell antibody Discovery using islands of
automation I'm Susie Valdez of labroots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Beckman Coulter Life Sciences to
learn more visit them at beckman.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during this presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Paul
Anderson the director of biologics
Discovery automation at Little League
biotechnology Center Paul welcome you
may now begin your presentation
my name is Paul Anderson and I'm proud
to present the work that we've been
doing at Lilly for the last several
years in automating a single cell
process used for biologics Discovery
specifically antibody Discovery I joined
Lily two years ago so a lot of the work
I'm sharing today is the work of a
fairly large group of people and you
know some of the people that helped make
this presentation and then had a major
role in in developing these systems are
my co-authors Mike Cohen Melissa crisp
and Tom kuchek so I just want to thank
them for the opportunity to share share
their work in the the group's work today
with everybody
so I'm going to dive into talk about the
process that we're automating here we
have several Discovery antibody
Discovery platforms at Lilly and the one
specifically I'm going to touch on today
is um uh immunization based platform
using single B cells and going through a
series of automated platforms to
generate lead molecules we have several
other platforms as I mentioned that will
are orthogonal to this approach that we
use for antibody Discovery as well so
this is the the main process I'm going
to be talking about is this single B
cell application but keep in mind a lot
of these systems are used in different
aspects of other ballet Discovery
efforts and so this topic this
presentation is really just honing in on
this application here so we have several
platforms I'm going to discuss
throughout this process and these are
really all tied together with a limbs
infrastructure so we are working on
collecting information from each of
these Platforms in the form of data as
well as sample tracking and so really
one of the overarching themes here is
the software side of the of the process
where we're capturing a significant
amount of data whether it be
purification amounts from DNA or
purified material amounts from expressed
antibodies data and associated with
titers
and a significant amount of screening
results toward the end of the process
and what we're trying to hand over is
really a data package so our project
teams can make informed decisions and
triage down to weed molecules as fast as
possible
so our process uh this particular
process starts with the
immunization-based strategy as I
mentioned so that could start with uh
mice or a variety of different host uh
host organisms or host species
in this example we're using a mouse
model and so we would immunize that
Mouse with the antigen of interest and
then once we have sufficient serum
tighter we would isolate the B cells and
use a back sorter
to dispense antigen uh dispense antigen
binding B cells into 96 well plates and
so we typically start with roughly 20 96
well plates so the process I'm going to
talk about here usually it's about 20 96
volt plates so about 2 000 single B
cells will go into this process as this
first pass the several projects where we
go through multiple passes several
immunization strategies and so they grow
significantly larger in size
so the first system we'll talk about is
what we call the film and barcode system
we developed with Beckman and this was
essentially a automated liquid Handler
with a series of other third-party
devices on there such as synamat a
labeler a sealer we added a balance
recently and really this system is
designed to add reagents to plates
barcode or label those plates seal them
up for to feed several platforms
throughout our process
with the
the case of where we're sorting cells
into plates we typically are using those
plates are created on here with cell
sore buffer and sealed up and stored in
a chilled manner until we're ready to
sort thousands them then once we sort
cells into these 96 well plates they
come back onto this platform when our
scientists are ready to process them and
and they are Consolidated into 3d4well
PCR plates and so the the next system
I'm going to talk about where a lot of
our molecular biology takes place this
system Feeds out as well adding
different PCR Max to mixes to a variety
of three to four PCR plates
and so the place come off of here
they've been Consolidated into 3D foil
plates and they would come to uh what we
call a molecular cloning system uh also
developed with Beckman and so on this
system I'm going to touch on some of the
usual suspects of instruments that
you'll see on several of the systems uh
coming up and so that would be a plate
lock and X peel and those are for
ceiling and peeling of plates as well as
a v-spin a centrifuge so that is
typically to to eliminate Bubbles and
pull samples to the bottom of a well and
there's several cytomats on other
systems so we have an ambient side
amount on this system as well as a
chilled cytom mat
so as we go through the presentation I'm
really going to try to touch on what
makes each of these systems unique in
their own right so the molecular biology
of the molecular cloning system uh the
kind of special sauce on this guy is the
Bank of automated thermal cyclers that
you can see in the top so there's a
stack three stacks of four
thermocyclists so Bank of 12 thermocyte
automated thermocyclers on this system
and this is what we use to carry out a
series of PCR reactions on here where we
start with the single B cell sorted into
each plate we split it to heavy light
chain and assemble it into our our
Vector of Interest so the output of this
system is going to be heavy in light a
set of heavy chain plates and a set of
light chain plates
assembled with the antibody chain of
Interest
the first QC step in our process
incorporates on the top left here you
see an ATI fragment analyzer so we
cherry pick samples after the second
round of PCR and this really we run
these on the fragment analyzer and this
lets us get some insight as to are we
chopping out the fragment of interest
and isn't it the right size and so this
is usually we have a fairly High success
rate of this but if there's anything
going wrong with our Master mixes or
anything went South in the Sorting side
of things this is where we would
typically catch our problems
and so as you come off of this system we
have our heavy and light chain DNA we go
into a semolina semi-automated E coli
transformation step and so we in a three
formula manner do a transformation into
competent cells let that sit for a bit
and then transfer those into 96 foot
deep well plates with lb broth and those
will sit in shaking incubators overnight
and
after that incubation overnight we
pellet the cells we Center Fusion pellet
the cells and decant them and seal them
and storm at minus 20 degrees until
we're ready to do our plasma
purification
and so the the next part is uh
we built a new a recent system to do our
plasma-based purification and we are
using the 96 turbo kit from kyogen and
so what we see here in the top left is
the E coli pellet block we have to
dispense a few different reagents to
resuspend lice and neutralize the E coli
and then we transfer those that material
into a lysate clearance filter plate and
samples go through that to clean up the
the garbage that's in those samples
that's kind of snotty viscous material
and it gets alluded into a DNA binding
filter plate you pull samples through
that filter plate DNA binds to the
membrane do a couple rounds of washing
and then allusion to to purify your plot
to do your plasma purification
and so as we approach automating this
there
are manual workflow involves vacuum
manifolds and there after this last wash
step we would do a centrifugation step
to really give a hard spin to these
filter plates to get rid of any residual
wash buffer before we do our illusion
automated vacuum manifolds are are quite
common but there are significant
drawbacks when you have samples that uh
could be if you have certain Wells that
don't have samples the vacuum is going
to pull through the path of least
resistance if you have other Wells where
either slow or clogged a bit then those
tend to not get pulled through once you
have swells around them that get pulled
through the vacuum the ones that are
clogged or running slower tend to be
more and more difficult to get to pull
to be able to pull through the filter
plates and so we in talking with back
when we had explored some other options
with how to proceed with handling filter
plate based purifications
and so
we had the idea in to explore positive
pressure devices so we we had this
discussion with Beckman they talked
about some positive pressure devices and
then we started looking into it more and
found several options on the market and
so we brought a few different devices in
that I'll talk about on the next slide
but to just give you a little bit of a
background on what these devices are and
how they different how they
differentiate themselves from vacuum and
centrifugation the way they they work is
pulling in house air it could be a gas
nitrogen or a different type of gas into
a pressure Reservoir so you have a high
pressure side on the reservoir and it
uses a flow restrictor and this is
essentially a software controlled to
uh open up small holes and let some of
that gas or air through and so what the
nice thing about this you're essentially
pushing samples through a filter plate
and whether you have an empty well or a
well that's completely clogged since you
have a large pressure differential
across the restrictor
you have the same amount of pressure
being applied to every well so whether
it's empty sample or a clog sample you
don't have those Wells impacting the
nearby Wells or adjacent Wells and so
it's a very nice consistent
um
flow rate across the plate which is
highly desirable the other thing is
essentially to get into these positive
pressure devices you're stacking in
unstacking labware and so that's a big
benefit as well because that's a fairly
simple mechanism to automate so while
vacuum is very inexpensive and and easy
to automate it it has some uh some
quality and reliability issues that we
would be concerned about
and so the centrifugation method you do
get Even Flow across all samples but is
a bit more challenging to automate
stacking and unstacking and the waste
associated with with plates uh going in
and out of the center Fusion so that
that was a bit more of a a red flag for
the centrifuge base
method of handling filter plates whereas
positive pressure it's a bit more
expensive I mean significantly more
expensive in the vacuum kind of on par
with centrify automated centrifuges but
it's very fast easily automated and the
flow control is is very good and so we
opted to explore this route a bit
further what we did find in our due
diligence is that this is essentially
somewhat this is very new for most
vendors and so the ones that we reached
out to they were just starting to
automate these types of devices and so
we brought in three devices from three
different vendors and what I'm showing
you on the top right here is in blue are
heavy chain DNA in in red are light
chain DNA and so we have control samples
which would be done manually using our
vacuum incentivization
workflow and then all three devices
performed well in our hands and so you
can see there's a bit of a bump in
constant DNA concentration with the
heavy chain and a significant increase
in DNA concentration with the light
chain plates
this was a I would
throughout the disclaimer that this is a
fairly quick and dirty experiment using
these three different devices not a lot
of optimization done to really dial in
flow rates and dial in other conditions
related to these devices so as a first
pass in some early data we were very
pleased and encouraged to explore this
technology further
what we did as well
um I mentioned in the first system we
have an automated balance on there and
you'll see that throughout the the
systems I'm going to talk about
we weighed the filter plates before and
after each of the liquid handling steps
and so to explain the higher
concentration on here what we think is
happening is after you do your last wash
step when you are pulling that through a
vacuum and then going to a centrifuge to
spin out as much residual wash buffer as
possible
there was based on gravimetric results
more wash buffer left on the filter
plate then when we were using the
positive pressure devices so we believe
that we were effectively eliminating
pushing through more wash buffer more
residual wash buffer
on the positive pressure devices and
then when you go to your illusion you've
reduced that residual wash buffer more
effectively on the positive pressure
devices and so our Aleutian had a higher
concentration of DNA so that's really
what we believe to be the the main cause
of the increase in concentration
and so we did look at the quality of DNA
we ran it on gels and I'm not showing
that data but it was it was right on par
with the the positive pressure device in
our normal workflow so we believe the
quality of the DNA was was good
and in the bottom right figure I'm
showing expression titers and so what
really matters at the end of the day for
us is how the yields look when we take
the antibodies pure the DNA that's
purified on these and we go into
transfection and look at what the
antibody yields are and so black bars
are a couple replicate plates and then
red purple and blue are the three
different vendors positive pressure
devices and there is some variability in
here but by and large we have run to run
and play-to-play variability uh that's
within this this degree on our
transfection system and so we believe
this the the DNA produced from these
positive rational devices
was right in line with what we were
we were looking for and so it was nice
to see those results
and so we opted to go ahead and work
with uh some companies and ended up
working with uh Beckman to design a DNA
purification system and so the first
system that was proposed was a biomech
i7 with two positive pressure devices
and they partnered with ampleus for
these positive pressure devices mounted
off the side of a biomech i7
and then we have again plate lock XPO
multi-flow for the reagent dispenses and
some bio shakes on this system as well
and we have a reader on here so as we
purify DNA we can go take a aliquot and
measure it and determine what the
purified yields are
and so what became apparent as we first
designed this system and uh looked at
what it would take to run 40 96 well
mini preps on here
the what I mentioned earlier was we
started this process with 2096 well
plates of sorted cells and those get
split into heavy and light chain plates
and so that's where the 40 96 wall
plates are coming out of the system so
when you look at the plates that are
coming in the tip box is required to
transfer samples from the E coli pellet
Peak well play onto the filter plates
the filter plates themselves Aleutian
plates and tip boxes to transfer to make
that aliquot evoluted material there's a
lot of lab where you can see associated
with this process as well as looking at
the time in the the models with Beckman
was 11 and a half or so hours just for
the DNA purification side of things and
so this led us to start exploring
another bottleneck on here which is
all the lab work that we have to have on
this system and so
what we took a look at was the thermal
Skyline that had come out right around
the time or just before the time we were
starting to design this system and so
this can be thought of like 14 Pez
dispensers and so without having shelves
and not you don't have a random access
like the the standard cynamats you
essentially can stack up filter plates
stack up your tip boxes and really have
a high density storage device on here
the other thing I mentioned is we have a
reader on here and we are able to
measure how much DNA we've made on here
well the next step is to normalize and
mix your heavy and light chain DNA and
I'll talk about that in a little a
little later in the in the talk
but since we have uh the information on
here and we have a liquid a Handler on
here
we have all the tools in place to be
able to do that mixing and so we modeled
that up as well and so that's where you
see additional labware uh on the right
so we have another set of tip boxes we
have the expressed uh the mixed DNA
plates which would be 96 deep well
plates and then we make an archive copy
which would be the 384 well copy with a
small amount of DNA and that's kind of
like our insurance policy if anything
goes wrong with the original plates that
we've made and so
when we model the DNA purification with
the mixing we're looking at roughly a 20
hour uh work a 20-hour workday or 20
hour Pro automated process to go from E
coli pellets all the way to DNA that's
mixed and ready to be transacted and so
that was a
quite a
it doesn't leave a lot of time if you're
going to do this in subsequent days and
a lot of this is going to be running at
night and so
what we wanted to look at we're also
exploring a couple new devices down here
the positive pressure devices as well as
the
thermocytomatch skyline and so to
de-risk ourselves a little bit we worked
with Beckman and they had a nice
proposal on
upsizing this system a little bit so
what we have here is what this final
system layout and it's another i7 with
two more positive pressure devices and
what you see are the skylines are
mounted directly underneath the biomack
i7s and with all the labware that we
were moving around the robot movements
start to become one of the bottlenecks
on here so by mounting these skylines
directly underneath and having the
biomech pull tip boxes and filter plates
directly out of the skyline and moving
on to the deck we're minimizing
transport times and speeding up the
system significantly and then having the
redundancy of essentially a mirrored
liquid Handler is mirrored positive
pressure of ice and purification systems
on here it gives us a bit of an
insurance policy as we you know
anytime you're automating new new types
of instruments whether it be the thermal
cyclers or the fragment analyzer you
know there's always unforeseen things
after you go through uh you know a
significant number of samples over a
couple years you start to find where
what things work and what things are a
little bit uh not as reliable or robust
so by having some redundancy on here we
really are are happy that we have some
insurance policy to keep the system
running at all time
and so we've put a balance on here as
well
um the balances are throughout the
systems you'll see are really to do some
automated uh verification so as we tell
our liquid handlers to dispense a
certain volume or to transfer a certain
volume we were weighing a lot of most of
the plates through our all our systems
before and after each of these steps and
this is uh our QC step to make sure our
liquid handlers are holding up uh as
expected
and so we have the positive pressures in
place we have high density storage using
the new skylines and so with the new
model for this system with some parallel
processing between the two uh two wings
of the system we can get the
purification down to a little over seven
hours and then mixing in about four
hours or so
so this is a pretty reasonable from the
number of plates we're putting through
the system a little over 11 hours for a
full purification and mixture
so from there we go to uh the protein
expression system that was developed a
few years back with Fujifilm or Wako at
the time now Fujifilm and so we take
those 96 well plates with normalize and
mixed DNA we put them onto this platform
we add our transfection reagents and
cells and then go into these uh cytomat
2C Tower shakers and so these are
shaking incubators and some of the nice
features of the system are we have four
cytomats that each have a 14 plate
capacity so 56 total plates can run on
the time
again when we developed this system
these Tower shakers were early days and
so by having a bank of four of them
that's been a nice insurance policy
where we've had issues that pop up from
time to time we're able to continue
running uh typical runs are in the 20 to
40 plate range so we're not using all
four at a time uh for most runs and so
this we're not using all 56 positions or
all four cytomets at a time and so we've
been able to to get by and keep our our
process moving forward by changing the
configuration of these on the Fly and
using as many signing mats as needed for
a given day
when we go through our process we uh
right now I'm talking about a 96 well
process and we're doing close to you
know a little under one mil Expressions
on this system
we
eventually get to a a point where we
triage these samples down and people
need more material and we'll purify
samples and so what runs on here is not
just 96 well plates but we also do two
and four mil transfections in 24 well
plates and those are all run in one run
on here in a and based on the barcodes
of the plates the system will recognize
whether they're 24 well samples 24 well
plates with two mils or four mil samples
or 96 will we call them one mil but
they're they're a bit under one mil in
total volume
and based on the barcodes the system
puts the plates on the different liquid
handlers to add transfection reagents
and cells and it uses the barcode a
suffix on the barcode to determine what
method to run for that plate so we treat
all the plates as the same and set the
system up in an identical manner in the
system applies different methods based
on the actual uh plate type it's running
so that's a nice feature of the system
and then we recently added a balance to
this system again for automated liquid
handling verification and then there's a
dispenser on here for some reagents that
has a nice manifold system so we have a
very viscous Solution on on this as part
of this workflow and so it does an
automated uh cleanup and washing of that
dispenser after hours and so that's a
nice feature of this system as well so
our DNA gets put on here we add our
transfection reagents and cells and
typically the next day they're getting
pulled off of the system and putting
into put into uh cooner shakers for
roughly a little under a weak expression
and so as they come out of that weak
expression then we put those plates with
cells that have been you know chose
cells typically expressing the material
over that uh six to seven day timeline
and then we'll go on to what we call the
Beckman Quantum cherry pick system we
typically refer to this as our IGG
system and so the the Workhorse
instruments on here are the bionics
hygiene centrifuges so these are really
nice centrifuges so if we have different
volume ranges uh and the the rotor and
the balance tolerance for these
centrifuges are are very excellent and
we can spin them at very high speeds
reliably and so we kind of decided to
upsize the centrifuge on this particular
system for those for that reason so we
have the bionics hygiene centrifuges we
have a fleet of NX is on here so we
pellet the cells on the in the
centrifuge then we use the biomech nxs
to transfer super native to a fresh
plate and take a little aliquot of that
into a three to four tilt welt plate
compatible with the octet so we're one
of the early folks obviously with with
Beckman in collaboration with Forte bio
to integrate the octet htx
and so we we take the aliquot of the
supernatant put it on the octet htx and
use the octet to measure our titers from
the crude super natives
and then that information using uh some
scripting that was developed with the
Beckman folks we are typically setting a
cut off for what we call an Express
sample around five micrograms per ML and
then we'll go to one of the other nx's
and then cherry pick samples that are
above that cut off and then leave uh
leave certain Wells or column empty for
controls for Downstream assays and so
we're typically measuring tighter on the
octet and then cherry picking and
rearranging the samples on another NX on
this system and again we'll we have a
recent balance on here we have a barcode
labeler so as we make new plates we're
pinging our limb system and then coming
up with new barcodes and telling one
system at the end of the process what
these new plates are where the samples
are and what concentration uh material
they have in them and so it's a really
nice platform that's uh that's been
really one of the Workhorse systems for
for this in several processes uh in our
Discovery efforts and then I'll talk a
little bit later we recently put some
bio shakes on here and where that comes
into play
so from this system we essentially have
supernatance of
a good amount of Express material that
we're ready to start testing
and so what we have
in place and what we've had in place was
these plates that come off the system in
their variable concentration
supernatants and these values were
determined on the octet and then we
would determine what our screening plate
setup would be and we would typically
need to normalize these variable
concentration samples using a lynx which
is a 96 variable volume pipetting device
to a flat concentration say 25
micrograms per ml and then from there we
would go into Tempo software that drives
our Echo access our labsite access
system and make those response plates
that would be used for screening and so
really the only reason that we're doing
this normalization step
is because the software that drove this
system require it was largely built for
the small molecule world and assumes
that the plates coming in are all of a
uniform concentration and so we want to
explore options to go from a variable
concentration starting plate to get to
the same dose response plate with a
software-based solution and so we work
with the folks at biosero and
Incorporated their transfer map workless
generating software and the the
scheduler green button go to drive this
system to do exactly this so we can now
take these variable concentration
supinate material take the same type of
dose response plates and then generate
workless and feed them to the echo to
accomplish this task and eliminate that
entire that normalization step and so
this is something that's been in place
for a good chunk of this year now and
it's it's been working nicely
so it's a nice example of a software
solution to really streamline our our
workflow a bit
so once we have our dose response plates
ready then one of our recent systems
late last year we affectionately called
the beast and that's a a bit of a play
on Beckman assay system and so it's a
the drawing doesn't quite do it justice
but the scale is far larger than all of
our other systems to give you a bit of a
flavor of the scale these this is a 1.5
meter precise uh robotic rail on the
right and on the left it's a two meter
rail it's a fully enclosed system with
25 HEPA filters on top capable of
running bsl2 screens so I'll start kind
of in the top left corner and go around
the system a bit so we have two gnfwd2s
they're mirror images of one another
flanked by a couple of stack of metlar
balances again for liquid handling
verification I'll talk a little bit
about that in a bit as well
but we have a suite of liquid handlers
including the wd2s and we have a service
over a Combi as well as two blue cat uh
blue washers and then we have Again The
Usual Suspects uh plate locks a4s
feelers xpos on here we have a couple
biotech spectrophotometer readers a
multi-mode reader from biotech as well
that's synergy neo2 as well as a high
throughput flow cytometer the Z5 from
biorad and then we go around to a
biomack ice i7 and you'll see a couple
positive pressure devices off the side
of that and I'll talk about a little bit
later on
and the i7s outfitted with the 96 uh
multi-channel head and the spin eight
and then we have the I5 that has a 3d4
head on there and then a couple side of
mats typically one's always at four
degrees and one's at 37 degrees
and so
it's really you can see most of the
systems I've discussed thus far are
built around doing a fairly fixed
workflow this is the kind of Jack of all
trades where we're going to run
everything from Eliza's to cell base
assays to high throughput flow assays
and and
it's large and it has a lot of equipment
but you know no screen incorporates all
the equipment you basically are looking
at what you want to accomplish with a
specific screen and applying the best
tools for the job and we have a lot of
tools on this system to be able to uh
to be able to accommodate any type of
assays our scientists would like to run
and the one thing I want to talk a
little bit about is uh the how the
balances are Incorporated onto this
system in particular and so we have
balances that work with our wd2s to have
a feedback loop to control dispensing so
when we got this system early on
we I put a bottle of two liter bottle of
PBS onto several of the different types
of dispensers on the system and just
dispense 20 20 microliters per well in
the 3D photo plates and repeated that
for uh hundreds of cycles and what you
see here this is normalized to 20
microliters and the theme of this is
basically all the dispensers drift over
time in a downward manner the service in
the wd-2 are using a similar dispense
mechanism where you're pressurizing a
bottle and opening up a solenoid biopsy
dispense and the combi is a peristaltic
pump driven dispense mechanism but
largely you can see the same type of
downward Trend over time this is
normalized and so the scale of this you
can see it's not a massive Trend over a
hundred to a couple hundred plates you
might only see a few percent difference
in volume but that's something that we
can be aware of and that's something
that we can control actually and so I'll
talk a little bit about that
the other thing is having the integrated
balances it's really an insurance policy
so if a bottle is an ice bucket and it
tips over or if you run out of reagents
you you can factor in the proper amount
of dead volume we have these systems
notify us and stop running and be able
to have a an operator intervene to fix
something and then to continue on and so
this is a the balances are a nice
feature a nice addition to the system
and so
what we've done with with uh Beckman and
other people have have done this with
other scheduler softwares and integrated
dispensers as well uh is to have the
feedback loop and to have the software
control dispense volumes so in the case
of the wd2s we are able to use that
information feed it back to the
dispenser and as it drifts down we it
bumps it up and keeps it dead flat for
the course of a run what I'm showing
here is another reagent that we
dispensed this is uh this is actually
filling up the the octet the octet
plates that would be on the IGG system
with uh with about 32 mic there's a
buffer so the octet's typically a one to
five dilution of the supernatant so we
fill 32 microliters of a buffer and then
eight microns of soups and so here we're
filling just a bunch of plates to store
in our refrigerator for future runs and
as we this is early days with the system
late last year and and we were sitting
there uh after the system set up and I
was showing the wd2s to somebody and
they're talking about e-stops and how to
control the system and how to respond to
errors in the system and then and right
after it finished dispensing 32
microliters to the 11th plate I said
well let's see it so it finished
dispense and I hit the e-stop right
before it released the plate to the
robot and so on the Sami side of things
you get a pop-up that says do you want
to ignore the error do you want to retry
it so just very quickly the user I was
working with hit retry
and so it already had 32 microtors per
well in the 3D full well plate so he the
retry is going to redo that dispense and
so now you have 64 microliters per well
and so then he was going around like oh
we need to stop the screen we need to
fix things and we'll start it back up et
cetera Etc
pull them back I'm like no no this is
the beauty of what we just worked with
back when to build into this system
watch the system and just let it go and
so
the next play obviously it thinks it
overshot this dispense and so the system
undershoots the next play to it
overcompensates a bit
and then within a few plates it dials
itself back onto set point and that's
kind of one of the shows the power of
this and so that was I think he was
pretty impressed to see that and then
using this to show other folks of how
we're controlling things is a nice
example of it obviously this is a gross
example and we typically would not have
this much of a discrepancy in control
and oftentimes what people are going to
talk about with a feedback mechanism
like this well how can you catch a minor
clog or a single tip when you're using a
8-tip or several Channel dispenser and
so
we determine the thresholds for what is
an error so usually
you are setting your thresholds fairly
tight around your set point and so if if
you do have one in eight tips clog
you're going to be you know 12 or so uh
off in that dispense volume so if you're
dispensing 20 microliters you're going
to want to stay
you want to probably keep that pretty
tighter within a microliter so plus or
minus a microliter to or maybe a couple
microliters to be able to catch those
types of errors
and so this is something we're pretty
happy with and we we like quite a bit
and so
as we work with our scientists and we
get protocols to run different assays it
would typically be something that looks
like this this is a generic protocol of
dispensing cells incubating
doing a transfer further incubation
dispense another incubate and read so
what the typically hand over to your
scientists is the reader data that comes
off the end of this experiment what
we're able to share with our scientists
now is every one of these incubation
steps we have a Gantt chart and we can
show timing and Sammy does that well as
well as cellular schedulers but with the
Incorporated balances under this system
not only can we show the Gantt chart
that we hit all the timing points that
they wanted we can also say well you
asked for 20 microliters 10 microwave of
antibody the detection reagent we can
show exactly how much volume uh based on
gravimetric results that these plates
were receiving and so if the data does
have certain Trends in them or patterns
then we're able to go look at timing as
well as dispenser performance to be able
to troubleshoot things so it's a it's
been a nice addition to our systems
so this is a recent uh assay and so
we've done a lot of covid-19 work over
the the last few months uh at Lilly and
and a big part of that is running
significant number of elizas uh on this
system and so obviously this system
would be very very Overkill if it were
just perform realizes and that's why we
have so much equipment on here to do a
bit more complex work cell-based assays
and high throughput flow cytometry but
this is a something the system's been
leveraged for and it's been performing
very well for us over the past several
months and so a typical Elisa process
would be uh you know do your wash and
block transfer samples add your
secondary a substrate and then the
system we do several OD reads and that's
one of the nice things is we can do
several reads because the plates are
always on there you have a ballpark of
based on our scientists that we're
working with of how long it should take
for development time but since we have
all the plates on there it's an
automated fashion we can read from just
a few minutes out to some of the plates
we read at 18 plus hours and so it's
it's nice to be able to just essentially
cue up the system and let it go until
these plates saturate and then we back
off and go to the time pointer a couple
time points before that uh when we're
looking at to try to get good exposure
without saturating
you do see a lot of steps in this
process for a somewhat basic Elisa and I
would say that that is because of all
the way steps so every way step is a
node and then the script to analyze the
way step is another node and so before
and after all these liquid handling
steps you're seeing a balance step
followed by a script node and so this
method is is significantly larger than
you might see on another Sami based
system and then one of the nice things
we're doing is our samples are coming
off in 96 well format and we're able to
use the biomech these ones are actually
being normalized on the links prior to
running the Eliza's so we have a flat
concentration of typically up to 96
samples in a 96 well plate and then
we're transferring into 3d4 Elisa plates
and on the i7 we're doing a four point
dilution so we're able to run dose
response plates in a quadrant format in
the going by going from a 96 to a 3D
floor well plate and so we've
generated results that look something
like this so the data coming off the
system is uh we're using a dart report
to aggregate the data coming off the
system and made spot fire templates that
really with minimal touch points take
that Dart report and drop it right into
a spot fire template to be able to get
what I would call kind of the 10 000
foot view of our systems and so we're
plotting Row versus column and
trellising by plate so this is two sets
of plates a one through eight and then
what we're calling B one through seven
so what I'm typically doing here is
sizing by the OD readout
and this is a three to four Elisa plate
and what you can see is
let me zoom in here on one of these you
can see a nice titration of some
positive controls so there's controls in
the First Column and there are two
fairly strong positive controls and you
see a nice titration again these are
sized by the OD readout
uh you see
towards the end of uh the a plate and
the last plate on the B plates there
aren't any samples in this portion and
so it's nice to see very consistent low
sizing of the squares and then again I'm
looking for streaks Edge effects other
patterns that might jump off the page to
indicate a liquid Handler issue in the
system so this is really not the final
analysis but this is what I would throw
data into a spot fire report like this
very quickly or even as screens are
running just to be able to see any
Trends and make sure that the quality of
the data is looking good and then from
this particular experiment you know
there are some Sledgehammer like really
really strong hits in play A2 that ended
up becoming important for us later on
and so from from the system I'm really
trying to
hit home the point that the functional
highlights on here we we can run Eliza's
it's very wide variety in flavors of
Eliza's cell-based assays high
throughput flow and then we can even
prep plates for offline instruments so
we have offline high content imagers so
we can do all the washing stain fixing
staining of the plates on here and seal
them up and and prep them for a high
content Imaging based assay and so it's
it's been a nice uh a really nice system
again kind of Jack of all trades on here
and we've got a a lot of equipment and
we've really been focused on Eliza the
last few months and so we're looking
forward to uh returning to work soon and
hopefully getting more cell-based assays
and we late last year and early this
year we got a little bit of high
throughput flow uh some high throughput
flow cell binding screens under our
belts and so we're we're excited to
continue on uh that effort when we can
get back to some normal projects
and so
I touched on this whole process and
going from single B cells to screening
results to generate lead molecules
but I mentioned a little bit earlier
when we're talking about the
transfection system is you know this is
all a 96 well format
um and the expression system we're doing
one mill samples as we generate these
leads and triage that list down the
samples do feedback in here a bit and we
increase we decrease the number of
samples but increase the volume and the
scale of those samples and so we
typically go into 20 foil plates up to
four mil cultures and at that point in
time we're typically not working with
crude supernatants when we're going for
our testing anymore we'd like to purify
that material so
early on uh or last year year and a half
ago we were scoping out a DNA
purification system as well as a protein
purification system I think you can see
here we purify a lot of DNA when we get
to the protein purification side of
things we've down selected the number of
samples pretty significantly so
it took a step back and tried to justify
that we should spend the money to
upsizing the DNA system and then do some
small modifications on our existing
systems to enable the protein
purification side of things and so
that's where I'm going to talk about
those those little tweaks that we've
made recently
and how we can enable the throughput
that we need for protein purification
and you know I've already shown why
we've and how we've upsized the DNA
purification system so kind of
reallocating the money where we get the
best bang for our buck
and so this is the the Beckman Quant and
cherry pick system again the what we
call the IGG system
and so as we pellet cells and harvest
the supernates and we measure the title
on the octet
well we can do 24 we can run 24 well
plates in this system in largely the
same manner but what we can also do is
use this the fleet of liquid handlers on
here to add resin
to those super names and then we seal
the plates up and then put them on the
bioshake for roughly 30 minutes or so
then what we would do is pallet that
Pelt those uh those beads of resin in
the hygiene centrifuge and then
where you typically are having roughly
four mils of sample and resin in the
plates at that point in time take off
the you've pelleted the resin so it's in
a pellet at the bottom of the well take
off the roughly three mils of supernate
and remaining on top of that so what you
have as an output of this system is
around one mil of liquid and resin in
these 20 Fallout plates and the antibody
is largely bound to the resin at that
point in time and we've done it uh
Mike's done and Mike Owens done a nice
experiment showing that we are capturing
uh nearly all of the antibody in the
super name and so from here we can go to
the DNA purification system where we
have the new i7 with a couple positive
pressure devices and use the i7 to
transfer those roughly one mil a sample
and the resin into 96 wall filter plates
and then use positive pressure the
positive pressure devices to push the
sample through the filter plates do
washing illusion and then use the
biomech to make an aliquot a again read
it on the integrated spectrophotometer
and then have the i7 take a work list in
and break out those samples by
scientists or request or a user so from
here we will
measure the amount of material and then
break the plates out and give people
plate maps of their purified material
and so again you know putting a couple
bioshake a few bioshakes on another
system and a couple positive pressure
devices on this guy and using all the
other equipment that we already have in
place really is a a little bit of
equipment to enable a whole nother
automated process that we weren't doing
previously
and so again this is the the overview of
the process
um and as I talked about in the very
beginning a lot of this is tied together
with a limbs infrastructure and a lot of
folks have been uh been helping on that
front so it's a huge effort not only to
build these systems with our team and uh
the collaborators such as Beckman and
Fujifilm and biocero uh it's been a lot
of work with the informatics folks and
the I.T folks to develop the
infrastructure the limbs infrastructure
for these
and so from this whole process and the
the whole reason why this all exists is
to really deliver
multi-species the lives of data cell
binding flow data functional cell by set
assay data and then when we purify DNA
back on the DNA purification system we
do make a cut for sequencing as well and
so by the time you have your screening
data coming off the right side of this
process you you have sequencing results
as well to tie that back too so it's
really a rich data set to give our
scientists as much information as
possible to whittle down our lead
molecules so with that uh again it's a
really huge effort I joined a couple
years ago so I'm very thankful to have
the pleasure of sharing the work from
the group uh but there's you know Tom
Melissa and Mike uh had a huge role in
this for several years uh before I got
here and David Lillian and Andrew are
are in my group and help at the
automation side of things as well and so
they've been everyone in my group is
Mike David Liliana Andrew are
responsible to support and keep these
systems running and work with a Beckman
and the the other vendors to improve
these systems and evolve them over time
and and our scientists that carry out
the Single Cell process our screening
group
as well as our sequencing folks you know
it's a huge amount of people in the what
we call the automation group all
underneath Tom uh that use these systems
have suggestions help of all the
assistance and improve them and then the
scientists we work with upstream and
downstream of us as well as the it folks
have a huge role in this and then we
have several Labs managers that help
support what we do but we're very
thankful for it and the management
support to be able to build out this
infrastructure and again our the people
we're working with at Beckman biocero
and Fujifilm to help develop these
systems and to continue to improve them
over time incorporating balances
integrating new devices as they come out
exploring new technologies and workflows
uh you know we have a
a lot of stuff to work on uh as we
continue our process and look for new
opportunities to incorporate new
technologies whether it be biology
driven or automation driven so it's
always uh it's a never-ending cycle of
improving these guys
well I want to thank you Paul for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some incoming questions from our
audience
our first question Paul do you have a
general sense of Hands-On time required
to set up and kick off a runs in each
respective module a follow-up would be
which process has offered the greatest
Roi for automating
yeah thanks can you hear me okay
yes oh great so the there there's quite
a bit of setup for for several of these
systems the DNA purification system in
particular is one that's quite involved
due to the The Fairly large number of uh
labware that are required for runs so
you have systems that can take anywhere
from 10 to 15 minutes to that system
takes upwards of a half hour uh possibly
a little bit more to set up a system
we've been trying to ease some of that a
bit from our scientists for the skylines
for example we're having some lab
support staff that are able to pre-load
the skylines with the kaija 96 kit
filter plates as well as tips so we have
extra racks for the skylines that will
keep uh pre-loaded on the side of the
system so when our scientists need to
run a system they can come over and pop
those on rather than unpackaging all the
consumables and loading the towers
themselves additionally we've put in
some cleaning and uh some priming and
cleaning systems on that automated mini
prep system the DNA purification system
as well as our transfection system we've
put in those cleaning systems that allow
a user to really plug in a bottle and
they don't necessarily need to then
Prime the system or clean it at the end
of the run the system will go through a
series of switch valves to Prime with
the reagent of interest at the beginning
of the run and at the end of the runs we
have scripts then to flip those those
valves to cleaning reagents to then
decontaminate and clean the dispensers
so that's also helped in some of the
setup time
we are looking at other things to Future
Technologies one of the ways
we're thinking of one of the things
we're thinking about in the mobile robot
space is using those to pre-load these
systems in the middle of the night so
you can think of this Fleet of islands
of automation that we have we could have
racks of tips plates other types of lab
wear where then a mobile robot you you
would tell however many plates you want
to process on each of these systems and
it would pre-fill those systems with
those uh those uh those tip boxes and
those plates ahead of time and then the
user in the morning would come bring
their sample plates on and fill up any
reagents or troughs so that's something
we're thinking about we haven't moved
forward on it yet but one of our uh one
of our ideas
thank you so much Paul now has the
system been used to generate other
Biotherapeutics such as peptides or
other recombinant
proteins
yeah that's a good question so we
we kind of have this islands of
automation approach where it's you don't
have to start at a and end to Z through
this process when we have antibodies and
that's our kind of Workhorse platform
those would typically go through all the
platforms that I discussed here we have
a lot of work in other types of
Therapeutics such as peptides and and
other type of vhhs and whatnot so we can
jump onto these systems at different
points so if we have someone doing the
molecular biology and the cloning in a
different setup
we can jump onto it at the next phase of
the process
we will have concessions on some of the
systems so when we go Express different
things and show if they're not
antibodies and there are other types of
of of samples when we go to harvest
those samples and measure how much we
have on the octet you know for
antibodies we're using the protein G
biosensors but for other types of
samples we use Pro a biosensors or we
use the streptovenin sensors and we code
on there different antigens so we have
some flexibility across our platforms to
be able to adapt to the different types
of biology and different types of
samples people want to process through
our systems
thank you so much Paul and I want to
thank our audience for these great
questions that are coming in our next
question are you doing any further work
on protein purification such as doe for
resin selection meaning the Upstream
process development on this system
yeah so on the systems primarily were
were automating a fixed process and
pretty well established processes we do
have some flexibility in there like I
just mentioned for the different types
of samples and how we handle those on on
some of the systems
for optimizing protein purifications as
an example we typically do that offline
using a lot of the same tools ideally in
the same instruments but we work out
those details off these systems and as
we're we're converting from say Maps
lecture to prison a or different types
of resins that we're evaluating that
would be done in a more manual offline
manner in those Matrix experiments and
then once we've worked out those
conditions then we update our automated
systems our automated processes with
those new conditions and so
we've had to make adjustments as we have
some upgrades coming in the early part
of next year due to some of those
changes where we're tweaking our
purification and we need to do a a
little bit different type of Illusion
and a larger volume so our illusion
plate is going to be not a normal
standard height plate it's going to be a
much taller plate so we need to look at
different types of devices to be able to
accommodate a little bit taller stack of
labware so that's that's something that
usually happens offline and then we
really try to automate something that's
a little more solidified but we always
try to build in the flexibility that's
necessary if our Workhorse protein
purification platform is is pretty well
established and we have we're really
trying to automate The Lion's Share of
what we're doing when we have histag
proteins and other types of proteins
that we do need to purify those are much
further and fewer between so we're
uh most likely going to push those to
more manual purifications because
they're not very frequent and focus on
automating the Lion's Share that we're
kind of really relieving the major
bottlenecks
thank you so much Paul and we have time
for one more question have you
considered automating any cell free
protein expression work on these
platforms
uh it's a topic that's come up from time
to time and I would say we're a service
part of the organization so if our
biology and our scientists uh find the
need for that and we have projects that
that need to go down that route then
we'll find a way to help with automation
like I mentioned earlier
we could automate different aspects of
it it could be kind of A to Z process or
we could automate different components
that would fit these different types of
workflows
and try to just relieve bottlenecks in
that in that manner so I would say we
don't have cell free expression
platforms automated at this point in
time but that's something that could be
changing the molecular biology system is
another example I'd highlight where the
type of mobile and the reagents and the
process that we do on there today are
very different than what we were doing
three four five years ago so
not only does our hardware and software
and automation components of the systems
change over time but the biology and the
processes significantly change over time
as new kits become available new
standards like best practices and new uh
new reagents become available we adapt
our process to to try to take advantage
of the latest greatest Technologies in
all respects
well I want to thank you for your time
today and for your important research
would you like to provide any closing
remarks to our audience before we go
I just want to thank Beckman for for
sponsoring this and lab roots for
hosting the the webinar and uh I look
forward to connecting with more people
on different Platforms in the automation
space through uh platforms like this and
the conferences coming up early next
year
well I want to thank you again Paul for
this great presentation and I also want
to take the time to think labroots and
our sponsor Beckman Coulter Life
Sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I want
to thank our audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone and bye-bye